welcome to this video playing persistent
fripp from the US and blatant before I
don't think so no no game so Kings
Indian yeah let's play the sims I'm
always trying to vary things and now we
probably get a position from the modern
benoni with e6e 693 ok you can always
insert that insert those moves ok um see
no I don't think so b5 i can safely take
with the sipping cpab Bishop b5
yeah here yeah it's a bit tricky now for
him to play you six as I maybe just take
it ok night ft 7 hmm ok yeah I don't
really believe he can take on c3 I mean
this looks totally totally risk him yeah
I think I can't ignore this for the
moment Bishop cc3 maybe night ft 7
intends to play mp4 at some moment and
then 95 will not be six to attack the
sea porn but I really have my doubts
that you can play like that oh ok after
six hmm now okay I essentially they've
given up a temple with not taking on b5
and tools but still I cannot believe
that this is a sufficient form of a
bank-owned against this f three setups
it's it's sometimes possible but
normally not working as white has this
quicker and always going to age fire
fire this is the Walt Walt set up um as
normally um you manage as YT r 2m to put
a piece on b5 and keep it there
supported by a form and the peas only
five mins that you'll play on the
queenside assume this really happened ok
so bishop d to simply or
my place see phone
okay let's let's think about this for
just a moment after taking on beef about
seven nite nite b5 just quite strong
maybe go here the night on g3 is not
very well placed anyway and if i go to f
2 i'm covering the d3 square which is
very useful if he goes c4 and on f true
it blocks the a7 g one diagonal for a
potential checks and it prepares f4 so
that no peace can go to g4 yeah ok it
makes some sense this movement and I'm
not quite sure what blacks movies when
yeah ok now i will take with the night
intending bishop d to c 3 yeah that's
the ideal post here for this bishop oh I
get this in actually that's nice again
yeah no I'm perfectly placed to to play
F for the exchanges strong pcl um yeah I
can even do it now but first night f2
looks even more promising getting this
night back into play
yeah this is basically a nightmare
version of the bangko with black having
zero playing on the green side and white
having central dominance let's just down
just fantastic position um question is
take your first night it probably does
not matter out of Queen d2 maybe take it
first and now be 3m this is make sure
that this never ever going to be c4
being played and on a captcha I
recapture with the bishop and this means
i'm totally in control of the queenside
roxy 122 and then preparing a
breakthrough on the Kings itest is next
yeah normally at some point they they
sacrifice an exchange against this piece
on b5 which is insufficient but it's
understandable if you want to at least
them yeah give the impression that you
have some active player
King edge one is because I want to at
some point probably move the night and I
don't want to be and ce4 check yeah okay
probably here protecting d5 and
preparing a five and this is the the
hopefully decisive breakthrough coming
okay yeah here I can even think about f5
can only go to e5 there may be an five
is stronger even you can get it to e5
but I can always exchange this night now
that's simpler really f5 I have quit g5
and and other attacking ideas so we'll
take it and Knight g4 or not there's
also strong maybe night h3 or take it I
take it first it's better he can this
this is capture right I need to have an
answer to that but that's just Queenie
to we're okay nighty for that's just
clingy to Queen you two nite moves
Queenie seven and over oops did I
overlooked some thing I hope not would
be really disappointing to not win this
for some reason
now I can just take this next move I
mean II 70 you for one of them we
wouldn't have taken only four I my next
idea would have been 95 e6 yeah breaking
through on the kingside I guess black
resigns yeah here if he does not take
there's a that's not g5 coming computer
gives this not g5 bishop CA to give to
with plus four yeah something like that
I headaches suspected it is just very
one-sided attack on the king while black
has absolutely no plane yeah the problem
is that there is no automatic
compensation would be five it simply
isn't if in this case here we look at
this in a situation like this where
white gets to place a piece on b5 like
the nightie and it is supported by a
form and cannot easily be challenged
then there is absolutely no compensation
what just has a pawn and yeah I mean the
whole centroid structure is in its
essence better for white anyway with d5
F or just cementing a space advantage so
if black does not have counter play on
the queenside really it's a very
one-sided affair and here we even got to
to the to the point where those bishops
are exchanged and without g7 next
position is completely devoid of any
hope it's just just just totally
one-sided I played it a bit a bit slow
we're just killing our counter play
first probably there were even more
forceful ways to play with quicker
advances but it's it's just the simplest
way to play also note that the knight on
d4 is only
optically an attractive piece it's
attacking nothing and just far away from
the king that's also very important
motif I mean this is just a piece that
will never ever help the king um
probably if we go back here yeah it is
maybe an idea to try to get this sorry
right f6 eh c7 this is the relatively
best idea maybe but not sure if you if
you still manage this this rook be eight
and so on is just a demonstration it's
not really doing anything you know God
was a pretty one-sided game but it's
really am due to this M sacrifice which
is not not correct simply against in
this in this particular circumstance you
sometimes can play it against air three
structures but not with the Queen being
misplaced here on a five and the night
moon twice so when there are sometimes
ideas that are possible like for example
on something like this year this is
possible and not so clear something like
this and then just oops just trial try
like this now keeping the Queen on on d
8 and only move it to a five in
particular circumstances well this is a
bit fishy maybe for blankets it's a
playable a play the line alright thanks
for watching